- Is Twitter taking a
lot from Facebook?
The quickness of Twitter
is such a factor.
All of you looked
at Twitter and said,
"What am I going to say?"
And I said, "Holy shit. I can
see what people are saying
and engage it."
And that's why I love Twitter.
People are in a false sense of
reaching mass audience
in Twitter right now because of
this enormous firehose of data.
Twitter has a firehose problem.
Twitter has gotten noisy.
Twitter is noisy as hell.
Nothing is more important than
the attention of the end user.
Nothing. The attention of
the end user is the cost
of entrance to
accomplish anything.
Twitter's struggling.
People don't understand it.
It's losing attention.
Instagram and Snapchat
emerged as major
attention grabbers
within mobile devices.
The first time I've been able
to make something trend
in the last three years was
this August when I sent a
Snapchat to 4,000 people.
And so I took a picture of myself
holding up a bottle of wine
with a hashtag and after those
5,000 people in two seconds
a ton of them
posted that picture
on Twitter with that hashtag
and I was able to make it trend.
They need to limit the things
that are being said or
the amount of people.
If you don't engage with
a single thing from
a person in a year,
do you need to see every
single thing they say?
They're not playing
the attention arbitrage.
The amount of people who you
follow on Twitter right now
that you don't care
about is stunning.
And this is email behavior.
We don't unsubscribe, we delete.
But you're not going to take
the hour to unfollow.
It's just the way we do things.
We don't purge.
It's quicker for us to just
go through the stream.
Twitter doesn't have an
algorithm like Facebook does
for the best content.
- If there's this person that
you have not clicked through
on their tweet for
a period of time,
six months or a year--
- Yeah.
- it should be automatically
or at least prompt you
do you want to delete it.
- Oh you mean the way
Facebook handles it?
The biggest damn
company in the world.
I think this is the television.
And that TV is the radio.
And it's 1965.
I think that this is the
number one device.
And I think that YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram and
Snapchat are ABC, NBC and CBS.
Think of Twitter as MTV.
What I think has
happened to Twitter is that
Snapchat and Instagram
have now become ESPN,
have now become the hot network.
The game is changing.
Quickly and often and
if you're not adjusting,
you're gonna lose.
They didn't ideate the product
over a long period of time
and they're paying the price.
I am so intrigued by seeing
what's going to happen.